This tells us pretty much the same thing that we get when we do a hypothesis
test for r. If the test for r is significant, then the test for slope will also
be significant. This is because both tests ask the same general question. Are
the two variables linearly related? So, let's just explore this a little more.
And that'll also give you a little review of the hypothesis test for r. I've
briefly mentioned that beta 1 is how we typically symbolize the population
slope. And beta not is how we typically symbolize the population, y intercept.
In other words, when we do linear aggression with all the population data, we
get that the best fit line intercepts the Y axis at beta not. Remember that
lower case B is the slop of the best fit line when we do linear aggression for
this sample. And we're using a for the y intercept for this sample. Now what do
you thing the null and alternative hypothesis are, when we do hypothesis
testing for slope? Do you think it's this group, this group, this group, or
this group?